myanmar's military has been
systematically torturing detainees in
the wake of pro-democracy protests in
the country that's according to an
investigation by the ap news agency
based on interviews with former
prisoners and people who worked in the
army the junta has arrested more than 7
000 people since a coup overthrew the
democratically elected government of
nobel laureate aung sangsuchi in
february this year and despite
international sanctions the junta's use
of torture to suppress democracy
continues
march 2021
people in yangon still had faith they
could reverse the month-long military
takeover
those hopes were crushed as the junta
moved in and swept up hundreds of
fleeing protesters loading them into
trucks
since then it's happened over and over
again leaving physical and mental scars
for the detainees
[Music]
nathan hmong was one of them
now back in the u.s the journalist
described his experience in the
interrogation center
he's like holding one of this you know
bamboo stick or something like you don't
know but he hitting me like this
it's like two hours and the guy was
standing behind me
start hitting
like
[ __ ]
dog
these images obtained by ap shows wounds
of former detainees they say it's
evidence of torture
they say protesters including women and
children were held in centers like these
the military dismisses the claims as
nonsense
but army defector hinyang pyong says he
witnessed the suffering with his own
eyes
since the start of the demonstrations
the police and army arrested beat
tortured people
they did it to everyone who were
arrested
i saw that two people died from their
physical torture
to improve its image the junta released
more than a thousand of around five
thousand detainees in october
but over a hundred of them were
re-arrested
activists call it mental torture in
addition to the physical punishment
endured in jail
human rights organizations say in
myanmar this is nothing
them using this new the religion ethnic
minority groups
um we've seen them using this against
the other ethnic minority groups for
decades and now they're employing it
against civilian people
now a free man hmong says he's finding
some solace in buddhist prayer but the
memories continue to haunt him
especially knowing thousands of others
remain behind bars
and joining me now from bangkok is phil
robertson he's deputy director of the
asia division at human rights watch phil
are you actually surprised to hear about
these reports of prisoners being
tortured in myanmar
no i'm not and that's kind of a sad
commentary because we have seen
systematic use of torture by military
governments in in burma in the past
and to see again this happening and to
be
reported by ap in such a
very conclusive fashion
really shows that it's a reversion to
past practice that with the military
coup they have brought in all their bad
human rights practices uh and again the
impunity that allows them to go forward
with this i mean no one is ever
prosecuted in the myanmar military for
use of torture
and uh this is why it continues to
grow and to be used systematically but
how are they getting away with it in the
21st century i mean how is the
international community
in a sense allowing this to happen
well it's an excellent question i think
that uh because we have not been able to
get traction on uh burma at the u.n
security council because of the
resistance of both russia and china uh
the whole accountability effort to
bring these uh various
perpetrators to justice
not only for what they're doing now to
the burmese people but also what they've
done in the past to
the ethnic rohingya in 2017 and to other
ethnic minorities all over burma that we
you know are
are really stymied in our ability to get
international accountability and
certainly at the national level in burma
uh the courts are beholden to the
military and will do nothing to
challenge them short of the u.n the eu
and the u.s have for instance already
import sanctions on members of the
myanmar junta but clearly that doesn't
seem to be
making an impact is it time therefore to
step up the pressure with newer and more
targeted sanctions i mean do we need to
look at the oil and gas industries
in myanmar for instance
well we are looking very closely at the
oil and gas
money that goes to the burmese junta you
know it's well over 400 million dollars
a year and that needs to be
cut off we have a lot of
proposals for that to stop the transfers
of money into
accounts controlled by the burmese
military but so far we've met a lot of
resistance particularly by the
government of france but also by other
states within the european union
it is unfortunate that we're not seeing
the kind of sanctioning that we need to
see and while we're hearing about a
possible new round of sanctions that may
be coming forward in the european union
uh it's it's again too little too late
it's been it's been
almost nine months now uh since we have
seen this coup and and what has happened
here uh people are dying every day
people are being arrested on mass people
are being tortured and the international
community can only come up with
statements
of condemnation
it's made the burmese people very
cynical and uh they're demanding more
action
does that basically mean that the people
of myanmar have been left to their own
devices they are left with their own
fate to try and stand up to this junta
to try and restore democracy in their
own country
well
certainly the burmese people think so uh
and that's what they're saying if you
watch what's happening on social media
and you listen to what they're telling
uh the few reporters who are still
active in the country is that it's on
them it's up to them to make something
happen and this is why i think we've
seen uh you know in a course of
desperation uh people taking up arms and
the growth of these people's defense
forces which are attacking uh the
burmese military and police on a daily
basis all over the country
the situation is sliding towards greater
violence rather than a negotiated
solution and part of that is because we
don't see the kind of international
pressure that is required
to uh bring the burmese military junta
to the table
phil robertson we'll have to leave it
there for the time being but thank you
so much for joining us today
thank you so much
you